my vision of this confidence is one
where they connect use of missile
systems science minerals question if I
products manga rules of them the benefit
of the applicants I think that if we can
get the memo the most example put some
value even if we're miring very few
bodies with them significant
fundamentals that are using canvas
public's change in ourselves and Africa
also be able to sell a mass finished
goods that we could have a party
tanning what we produce MGR boots send
out the most important things that
require heightened young people
constitute alive if we come
provide them with education they are
well what's about skills with the
concerned thinks the clown in two
finishes I think that we would be able
to only support ourselves but also be
able to exchange the other who's that
fish that means that we must level of
education make additional medical to all
I am it such as we found all these
energetic people
should be a bus fortunately when we are
not able to fish ask him boy I am and so
my view on the continent in saqqaq is a
few sales and this conference which we
have all these young people educated
take any pain so that they're able to
next fews the source of this country I